hi everyone
welcome to yet another video tutorial on
the top 10 reasons to learn python in
2022 python's popularity has grown
exponentially over the past few years
and is being widely used in different
jobs
so this video will focus on the
different reasons why it is important to
learn python in 2022 let's begin
the first reason we have is python is
versatile
python is a totally versatile language
as it has been used widely in artificial
intelligence data science machine
learning web development embedded
systems graphic design applications data
mining gaming and others
python is used as an easier and more
effectively written alternative to
languages that perform similar
functionalities like r and java
now talking about the
second reason why you should learn
python in 2022 we have python is the
fastest growing programming language
python programming has
become one of the fastest growing
programming languages in the world and
is the primary language for many
applications
its popularity has grown both in india
as well as in the us
in january 2021 python was in the third
position in the dob index in january
2022 which is this year python has
become number one in the top index of
popular programming languages
the ratings are based on the number of
skilled engineers worldwide
courses and third party vendors
popular search engines such as google
bing yahoo wikipedia amazon youtube and
baidu are used to calculate the
ratings coming to our
third reason that is python is beginner
friendly
the main reason why python is an
excellent choice for beginners is its
simplicity
python supports english syntax and is
designed to be concise and easy to read
all of which make it more accessible to
first-time coders
it is an interpreted programming
language this means that you can run
each line of code once you have finished
writing it allowing you to immediately
check it and make adjustments if needed
the fourth reason we have is python
libraries and frameworks
python provides numerous libraries and
frameworks that cater to every need of
the user and its clients
it has numpy and pandas for numerical
computation and data manipulation scipy
for scientific computation matplotlib
and c-bond for data visualization
scikit-learn for machine learning stats
model for statistical analysis and much
more
python also supports frameworks such as
flask and xango for web applications
you can also do cross platform and cross
browser testing with frameworks like pi
test and robot
now moving ahead
the fifth reason we have is python for
data visualization
python is a great programming language
for data analysis and data visualization
so it supports libraries such as
matplotlab c-bond bokeh and plotly for
creating interesting visualizations
you can make sense of complex datasets
and visualize your findings through
various representation options like bar
graph pie charts graphical plots
geographical maps and much more
now moving ahead
the sixth reason we have is
extensive online documentation
python has been adapted to the latest
advancements with developers
continuously releasing new and improved
versions
python language is very organized and
its libraries have co-existing
documentation letting you jump start
straight into programming
you will also find example codes where
you can see the functions implemented so
reading the documentation is a good way
to improve your knowledge about python
moving on to the seventh reason why you
should learn python in 2022 we have
python is great for scripting
python is also used to write scripts to
do automated tasks such as backups and
cleanup in servers
in python you don't have to compile the
code in order to interpret it you can
directly write code in the script and
execute it the machine reads interprets
and runs the required tests and also
performs error checking
now coming to the eighth reason we have
python for cybersecurity
python has been dominating the
cybersecurity industry and has been
around for a long time now
it can help to automate tasks across the
cyber attack life cycle for both cyber
attackers and defenders
you can develop custom python scripts to
automate cyber security tasks with
libraries such as nmap yara scapy and
twisted
python is used heavily in malware
analysis host discovery
sending and decoding of packets
accessing servers and network scanning
now moving on to our ninth reason we
have
python community support
you always need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language
the python programming language has a
global community with millions of
software developers who interact online
and offline in thousands of virtual and
physical locations
in case of any coding related issues you
can always seek help from the python
community
as shown on the screen python has a
robust and supportive online community
with over 1.5 million github repository
communities such as stack overflow also
brings several python experts together
to help newbies
now moving on to the
10th reason in our list we have python
jobs in high demand
as python is getting more popular along
with an increase in an active community
and its functions the demand for python
professionals is also increasing
python jobs are increasingly growing in
every business sector and provide high
salaries
python developers is one of the highest
paid jobs in the united states
the average salary of a python developer
in the us is over 96 000
so those were our top 10 reasons to
learn python in 2022 i hope this video
was useful thanks for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here